ファンダメンタリストという概念は、本質的に
量子力学における測定の概念と結びついています
量子力学が発展する以前は
科学者の間で一般的に知られていたことがありました
ある状態にあるシステムがあれば
その状態は確定しており
測定を行えば
明確な結果が得られるということです
量子力学ではそうではありません。完全に
明確に定義された状態にあるシステムでも
特定の測定を行うと
ランダムな結果が得られることがあります
この概念を説明するために
重ね合わせの概念を導入する必要があります
重ね合わせとは、直感的ではない概念です
これは、複数の状態の線形結合を
同時に表現しているというものです
例えば、
さまざまな周波数を運ぶ電波のように考えることができます
それ自体には
量子的な要素は何もありません
重ね合わせに量子的な特徴を与えるのは
システムを測定するという事実です
例を挙げて説明しましょう
矢印のシステムがあると想像してください
そのシステムを準備して
すべての矢印が左を向くようにします
そして、その矢印に
「上向きですか、下向きですか」と質問します
すべての矢印に聞くと、矢印は左を向いているので
これは
上と下の重ね合わせとして
表現できるため、結果は
50パーセントが上向き、
50パーセントが下向きになります。「上ですか」と聞くと
そのような結果がシステムから得られます
次に、別の状態のシステムを準備できます。
その状態では半分の矢印が上を向き、
残り半分が下を向いています。同じ質問をすると
同じ結果が得られます
これらは全く異なる二つのシステムです
しかし、同じ情報しか
得られていません
今のところ、
どうすれば違いを見分けられるでしょうか
二つのシステムは実は全く異なります
最初のケースでは、システムを
純粋な状態に準備しています。そのため
システムに対して確定的な
つまりランダムでない答えが得られる質問ができます。「左ですか右ですか」という質問は
100パーセント「左」という答えを返します
二番目のケースでは、100パーセントの答えが得られる質問は
存在しません。なぜなら
それは混合状態だからです
左か右かを聞くと
ランダムな答えになります。半分が上を向き、
半分が下を向いているからです。上か下かを聞いても
同じです。50パーセントになります
これは量子のランダム性とどう関係するのでしょうか
コインを投げることと
似ていると思うかもしれません。表か裏かになります
でも、コインを投げるのとは全く違います
なぜなら、コインを投げるとき、
結果がわからない唯一の理由は
知らないからです
コインを投げる力、角度、その瞬間の
室内の環境条件などを
すべて知らないからです。もしそれらの
変数をすべて知っていれば、表か裏かを予測できるでしょう
それらは観測者には隠れた変数です
長年にわたり、科学者たちは
量子力学にも同様の変数があり、
それがランダム性として現れると考えていました
しかし、
1960年代のジョン・ベルによる画期的な研究によって
そうではないことが実証されました
そして今では、すべての物理学者が
隠れた変数理論は存在しないと
量子力学と両立する形では成り立たないと認めています
つまり、システムを測定するとき、
自然がその結果を明らかにするのは本当のことであり、
どれだけ考えても
驚くべきことだと思います